[Music]
the first act Rick and the president
it goes from irritating each other
step two is there's a huge threat in
step three as they solve it together
yeah so I'm done yeah I mean that's the
now it's all just down to the down to
the nitty-gritty of it all the first
beat is why are they miserable well what
do you see what do you think of this I
mean perfect what did you read it I
guess I didn't do a good job of bluffing
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's perfect
here's where Rick like reveals lay or
hear somebody say like Rick Rick it's
like while you were doing that [ __ ] I
did yeah I solved the Middle East
Burns's breeches [ __ ] comes to a head
thing in the fight go to commercial like
but I think that's a look at it like
this this is our new act structure is
that this impact one got it so oh I see
yes so then go coming back it's like
you're just doing a beat here of what
you had numeric and then and then and
then president president werewolf hunter
yeah
and then threat that's what you had
written is like yeah like like Isis
werewolves then the president and or
Greg code to each other and they have to
meet and hash it out they do a shot they
they hug it out and then they get to
work
then the third meet is just [ __ ]
nonsense it's just that kickboxing yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
version of eye of the tiger so you can
use it moving upward into the night
you've got strength and energy all of
your muscles are feeling right just a
man fighting to feel good it's the sight
of the predatory cat
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie the Rick and
Morty people are busy in the writers
room so they're dropping new stuff to
celebrate and Comic Con is coming up so
I'll break everything down if you're
brand new to the channel we're still
doing that season three blu-ray giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this if you've been watching the season
3 blu-rays you probably heard them talk
a lot about stories that changed a lot
while they were still breaking it so
what they're doing right here is them
breaking it then after they would finish
this a writer would go off do a draft
then come back in this version for this
particular episode they said that it
went through a whole bunch of drafts
which is one of the reasons for the
season 3 delay what are the big
criticisms that Dan Harmon and the
writers had of themselves is that they
over wrote like they rework things over
and over just in the name of perfection
so that's one of the reasons why it took
so long for season 3 to get here
obviously they posted this because they
started season 4 so it's like hey we're
all doing this again like they've
already started turning in drafts and
even though Comic Con is a couple weeks
away the weird thing is is that Adult
Swim still hasn't announced their Comic
Con plans if it's anything like last
year they didn't announce any of their
official plans till it was like July
10th so as I'm posting this video we're
not quite there so it might be a couple
more days before they say what it is
they're doing what their panels are
gonna be usually there's some Robot
Chicken usually there's some Rick and
Morty even if they don't have a new
season to drop usually there's some sort
of animatic or they do a live read if
you haven't been to the Rick and Morty
panels in previous seasons they're
usually pretty good they're very
entertaining because if you're not a
harmontown ban dan harmon has perfected
his live show ability one of the best
Rick and Morty examples of that is when
they just magicked up an episode on the
fly to promote season 3 this was right
before they premiered the season
officially in July Morty Morty wait I
just discovered something about these
two characters they have they could kill
us so powerful that they could [ __ ]
kill us in our sleep we shouldn't joke
about them that's the year we live in
pretty geez coca-cola Pepsi yeah but
they're [ __ ] each other
so this time getting really drunk and
just watching Dan Harmon type is they
throw ideas in his head Dan Harmon has
this weird skill where he can do this
like even if everybody is talking in a
room at him they said that this has
happened in the writers room before
where like they're all trying to break a
Rick and Morty episode and he'll just
start typing while everyone's still
talking in his ear and it'll just wind
up turning into some awesome scene
usually on most television shows
especially shows that do a lot of
episodes like Rick and Morty has 70
episodes to fill and even if it's an
hour-long drama show usually they'll
spend a couple weeks breaking in episode
where they sit around talking about
ideas like that's the thing that they're
doing in this video is they're trying to
break the story then a writer goes off
for a couple more weeks writes a draft
comes back then the writers room will
tear that apart and completely rework it
and if they need to the writer will go
back into another draft or if it's been
a little too long or they feel like it's
ready to move on to the next stage one
of the senior writers or Dan Harmon the
showrunner will do his draft then
they'll pass it along it'll go to
animatic they'll start talking to the
animators about what they wanted to look
like in the thing that they've actually
changed about the production process
from the early seasons of Rick and Morty
is that the Dan Harmon said that what
they used to do is as they would agonize
over like little line readings in jokes
and dialogue before they would send
episodes to animation so it would take
extra long to get episodes out but in
animation as long as you have most of
the character moments and the scenes all
worked out you can actually change a lot
of the jokes after it comes back from
animation you could re-record dialogue
to fit what the animators have done so
as far back as the end of season 2 they
said that they were trying to learn to
use that to their advantage more like
the script doesn't have to be absolutely
perfect we can make these jokes better
when the episodes come back from
animation so that's the big thing like
just getting episodes to the animators
so they can start working on them I've
talked about this in the past but if
they can get all their scripts to the
animators by the end of the year then is
a pretty solid chance that they premiere
season 4 next year the dolt Swim has
really liked those summer premiere dates
the last couple of years but if you
remember the first season of Rick and
Morty actually premiered in December of
2013 so I don't think that they're
opposed to premiering episodes later in
the year just depending on when they
finish
and have a big white Santa Claus beard
there just a couple premiere windows
that television shows like to hit like
either it's spring summer or fall
usually what'll happen nowadays though
official is really popular especially
with younger people like Rick and Morty
is they will try to wait till spring or
summer till most of the population is
out of school just because people tend
to watch television less when school is
in session
so whereas people used to think that
summer was a dumping ground for TV that
nobody wanted now it's the place where
you put all the really big shows that
younger people especially Millennials
watch and if you're a big stats geek
Rick and Morty during season three was
the most watched show amongst
Millennials worldwide like that's how
crazy popular it was that's also why
they spent so long trying to negotiate
for multiple future seasons of Rick and
Morty so they were worried like if they
had this gem on their hands they didn't
want the network to mess with it
so they wanted to lock down 70 episodes
so the network couldn't fire them and
then hire someone else and completely
changed the show what'll happen is is
I'll do a new video when they do
announce their Comic Con plans or if
they do say the last minute no we're not
going to come we're gonna be doing
something else they'll be more comic-con
videos in the next couple of weeks
they've almost finalized what all the
big panels are gonna be so I have a
pretty good idea for the videos that I'm
going to be doing for comic-con
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Dean Wilson please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for more new season four and click
here for my ant-man in the wasp
post-credit scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]